you you're a minister the last time we
had a three-day week um in an energy
crisis now i remember the student being
locked out of the laboratory and had i
been the sort who went to the library i
would have had to go there in in
daylight hours
are we heading in that direction again
i think that
we are heading to a significant increase
in inflation
which will lead to increases in interest
rates and if i was chance of the
exchequer i would be extremely worried
about all the demands which are you
heard the labor spokesman now classic
labor spokesman spend more money uh six
billion on the universal credit
subsidise the gas industry
plenty
these prices in industry out of industry
are going to come now in fast and thick
in the ensuing months and every time
there will be a demand for more
taxpayers money
what of course they never tell you but
the economists are all writing about it
is that sooner or later there's going to
be interest rates increases which of
course will impact very dramatically on
very large numbers of people
particularly those with mortgages so
look this is very nasty situation it's a
very complicated situation and
i can well understand the government's
reluctance to introduce what will always
be called a temporary palliative these
palliatives are never temporary and they
become built into the system and
we're already
running on
both times so to speak in economic terms
but would you
um take the
i won't say relax but but the sort of
the view that your successor in
what is now department for business and
energy and industrial strategy um
that actually in a way we need to get
just get through this and not panic i
suppose he would say
it's hard to see him from hearing him
this morning promising a conservative
party conference as you did 30 years ago
that you would intervene before
breakfast tea and dinner are you happy
with this um stance of the conservative
government
no i'm not i think that uh
the the urgent need is
to devolve power in
england
to effective local community-led
organizations
and to pursue strategies
relative to the strengths and weaknesses
of those local economies and
we've we've missed every opportunity
over the last two years we've set back
seriously the agenda that george osborne
and greg clark and david cameron pursued
when i was helping them in the
10 years ago and
we're now faced with
a budget in a couple of weeks and a
white paper on devolution
michael gove's speech the conference was
very disappointing
but
the leveling up agenda is totally
dependent upon a change in the
government's approach to the way we
spend money raise money use money
and
it is based on what civil servants in
london think are the best ways forward
whereas in every other advanced country
you have powerful local leaders who
relate
the available cash to the circumstances
on the ground
and that is what we failed to do
i i want to come to that issue of local
power and so on but um why did you find
michael gove's speech disappointing
well he didn't say anything
that's the truth of it it was all words
um no plan no action no detail
um so we're waiting now on the white
paper
uh and
i travel with optimism
as always but
i can't pretend that there are any
grounds from an optimistic assessment on
anything's happened so far
well you you've marked mr go's school
report what did you think of the prime
minister's essay at conference
well
i think that
he he obviously wanted to
um
get the boys and girls on site and he
succeeded in doing that and after all
that's an important part of a
a party conference i've had some
experience of it um but the universal
commentary i think
is that he missed a great opportunity
because again
you know there was all this talk about
leveling up
but the language means nothing unless
you have an agenda and a set of
proposals and he didn't come up with any
uh again i repeat myself is michael go
going to cover up with anything in a
couple of weeks time
fingers crossed
um well let's
let's see
i think bob is also made
yeah well perhaps i'm a bit over
sensitive but blaming everybody else
especially previous conservative
governments uh for where we were well uh
he's got the guts he said to do
something well let's see because so far
all we've heard are words and words
don't create wealth
let's see if mr gove and mr johnson can
learn anything from
the past and past experience um you you
won't remember this but i did interview
you um more than once in the mid 1980s
on this issue of devolution and your
view was that ministers had to get stuck
in i remember you taking coach loads of
business leaders to merseyside and
essentially standing on the docks and
saying
invest and and so on
do you think that's sort of thing that
ministers need to do now
well look what happened on most sides it
is the place transformed
i don't like all these troubled pictures
let me say but i can tell you that
liverpool is unrecognizable the
liverpool of the 1980s but so are many
other parts of
england
where dramatic intervention took place
in parts of manchester for example
uh and the hume estate uh the banks of
the time
wherever you look where the government
took positive actions not just east
london
you can see what we need to do i mean
this is what is so frustrating that
let me make it personal if i was in
number 10 today i would know exactly
what needs to be done and i would do it
in 24 hours and it means simply saying
to the elected mayors
what is your plan agree it with us and
we will back it
i would say to certain other areas which
i ought to have elected mayors
nottingham derby the bottom of the
solent perhaps plymouth
we're going to create a male
authority there and
we will
start the process of regeneration i
would then look at the counties which i
i think broadly represent local
economies and i would do deals with
those counties on it
providing they were unitary and they had
a mayor and they would then be part of
the great regeneration of england and
what am i saying i'm saying i would
implement the 1968 redcliffe moor report
which was the last serious analysis of
how we make this country competitive and
how we run it effectively and it would
make it broadly similar to all other
advanced economies of our sort
yes for those of us those who viewers
who are not of our vintage red cliff
moored was a government commissioned
report into essentially governance but
of course it was very much focused on
the idea of uh how we made the regions
prosper and and so on but
let me put it to you that um
you are very critical of the current
government some people would say that um
you're criticizing boris johnson's sort
of cheerful boosterism but some people
would say that if you were to go back to
your time in 1970s 1980s what he's doing
is not that far from what you tried to
do which was also boosterism
well i'm sorry i don't recognize the
comparison what i did was based on
action on decisions to create
structures with local leadership with
the resources to do the job they were
called development corporations they
were called city challenge
and
it was the use of the
land grant
in partnership with local industrial and
commercial figures
all these were policy implementations
and the the other characteristics was
fundamental wherever we did anything of
that sort there was one identifiable
person in charge
now what we've got today
is a government which is in serious ways
reversed the processes that david
cameron's government pushed and it has
put nothing positive in its place except
boosterism and boosterism frankly
well
it's good it's good for those who
believe
in you
but it's no good for people who are
waiting to take positive industrial
decisions investment decisions inward
investment decisions local
strategic decisions
just saying it's going to be all right
it's going to be better let's
just take the phrase take back control
now that's what we were told brexit
would do take back control can you show
me any area where you think this
government has actually achieved a
greater degree of control
it is lurching from crisis to crisis and
it's patently not in control
well next time we have the prime
minister on i'll ask him that but let me
just put one
thing that he might say or other
conservative ministers might say
that the principal effect of all the
cash that you poured into merseyside and
you're now suggesting should be given
for example to mayors like andy burnham
is to
hand it to hand money as you did to
militant dominated councils make derrick
hatton a household name
and that what tories might reasonably
fear now is that all you're going to do
is make leveling up mean more cash for
labour councils
well i think you probably can't have
been to manchester very recently or to
liverpool uh or to the west midlands or
to ties valley or newcastle wherever you
like where these interventions are now
factual
working
have brought about dramatic change
um so
i'm afraid
we're not on the same planet when you
look at what has happened now just take
the fundamental issue of um derek hatton
who came incidentally after i had done
the various interventions uh in in
liverpool initially
and the the answer to your question is
this
leveling up is not a question of saying
here's the cash you get on with it it is
effectively creating a partnership
between
the government departments in whitehall
and the local elected mayor in the area
we're talking about
and so
there isn't a capacity for a local mayor
to say i've got the money we're going to
nationalize everything in sight we're
going to do whatever
mayors of that characterization would do
they can't do it they could only get
agreement for their strategies if the
government approves them
and that but the point is instead of
being individual ideas from individual
spending departments transport housing
education whatever it is they become
part of a local strategy relevant to the
different circumstances of every
different connotation
that's a very important step
and so
as i said
every other advanced economy in the
world works on this basis and works
effectively on this basis we have a
situation where london works out the
ideas they think and then
imposes them by the use of cash grants